so my producer came in this morning and
he he said that he saw a commercial
that was so vague so generic
that it was going to be almost
impossible to guess what it is so
he asked me if i could do that i will
now watch it and give my best
expert analysis to try to figure out
what they're talking about
[Music]
i think if you look around at so many of
the technologies that are available
today
just like the brilliant misogynist
association of america is just sort of
a lot of times making fun of women for
not having a lot of inventions you think
that all the knowledge has already been
acquired or how can you further
it but that's when adventures come into
play
they constantly push the boundaries of
what we think is possible
is this gonna be like a girl scouts
thing things that don't exist yet
because no i guess the girl scouts are
the boys now anyway so that's okay
to happen you kind of let your brain
be free who knows maybe you can actually
make it something real
back in the old days women were in the
kitchen women looked pretty on the stage
but now women and girls are building
things yeah back in the old days women
were good cooks and were pretty but now
they're terrible cooks
this is like more misogynist by the
minute eva i'm 16 and i'm from ireland
i'm working on an invention that detects
the amount of
harmful dyes in soft drinks and sweets
[Music]
wow my name is gatanjali i'm 13 years
old
and my invention helps detect blood and
drinking water
wait so don't don't the soda companies
know how much dye they put in their soda
why do we need an invention i am 16
years old
and i'm working on an invention to
detect sinkholes before they collapse
what's this one
[Applause]
stop it you gotta be
kidding me it's
it's a commercial it's a commercial
for a board game it's
uh that is i gotta tell you of all the
i i was totally confused i had no idea
what that was gonna be
but if you gave me 10 million guesses i
would not have guessed
that this sort of vague political
politically correct ad about the
patriarchy you know
inventions and lead in water and what it
is about
a slightly differently drawn
board game with miz you know is there
any hope left for america even
capitalism has sold out
even even rich uncle pennybags is now
being replaced
with betty friedan time to give up on
the culture folks that's it
[Music]
[Music]